so you're in you're in Ibiza right now
that's where you're I think you've been
for the last few months yeah exactly
correct time what does uh what does
lockdown like there compared with other
places in the world am insane was pretty
heavy we lowdown well we weren't allowed
out for any exercise or anything as we
were in the UK but I'm but I have a
garden and the sunshine so not too bad
yeah must be nice to spend time with the
family I imagine it's like the most time
you've been able to spend in a row in a
long time probably definitely it's been
actually amazing how about you it's
actually the it's the same and it's been
really nice to just spend time with the
kids every single day really yeah um
yeah it's a bit of a gift isn't it yeah
I love the the picture of your NHS
workers that you drew the of the health
heroes that you do on Instagram who's uh
what are your kids think of your
artistic skills I think they have pretty
good taste in music so when I normally
start they normally tell me to shut up
so I mean they're super young but but
yeah that song was a it's called the
greatest it's a song I wrote for them um
my children patisserie to them they need
to be the greatest really when they got
older to fix the problems we had left
them but then I suppose through this
virus this pandemic we've really
recognized who the people are have
stepped up to this and that's health
care workers they are the greatest and
then so that the song I've released with
a video dedicated to them and proceeds
going to them yeah I love that the the
proceeds are going towards the workers
what's the response been so far it's
been amazing I mean I think we're not
the album as a whole people can really
recognize those about real things you
know if you're writing songs for your
kids I'm writing songs for my father
who's been very unwell needing a kidney
transplant people would consider those
songs onto the music business there
they're really from for me instead
deeply personal and so people are really
connected and and and I think you know
when people have gone home during a
lockdown there's a certain amount of
fear you
one's health and fear for one's
financial situation - and it makes you
reflect it about where we're at and I
suppose that's perhaps why they've
enjoyed this music I got really
emotional watching the video for
monsters you know just thinking about my
dad thinking about being a father as
well what was it like for you actually
sitting with your dad recording that
video how emotional did you get it was
super heavy
um and everyone on the set was crying
other than him and he was still alive it
was bad yeah as amazing to have him on
set and capture him in film immortalized
in film and um and I wrote the song you
know because I felt fear for his life
and I could only write it because I have
my own children because it went because
the children took the monsters and at
night and then realizing that as my
father was becoming more frail it was my
turn to look after him like he did for
me when I was younger to capture it on
film was very special and he looks
fantastic
and he's a natural and how is he doing
now have you you must have you talked to
him this week um ah it's Tuesday I
haven't given a buzzer must do that he's
he's alive and well he was given a
transplant in January his name is
Charles Blount and someone called
Charles Blount gave him a kidney of his
and and so again you know I I uh
doctors and nurses a lot this year
that's it's incredible it's a lot it's
that's a fantastic you know your this
album you know you'd mention how
personal it is the story is coming out
of your life even your fears and your
responsibilities how does music help you
sort through your life sort through your
emotions and your thoughts well I think
on some previous albums I've done it in
different ways my first album was called
back to bedlam but very honest and open
it because I just wrote not knowing
anyone would ever hear it about my my
place in the world as a young man coming
out of the army with a dream and so you
can see a you know self orientated songs
with young young man's questions and
then as with success came the rejection
of that and the struggle with fame and
then and then I got more comfortable
with that and I wrote songs just about
being with a song that I thought maybe
people would enjoy in the music business
and I think that's probably where I
started losing my real my honesty
because if you're writing songs for
other people it's not you're not really
writing songs for you and and from the
heart and I loved them and I'd really
enjoyed them and I had great musical
inspiration I'd work with some amazing
people but from Ed Sheeran Ryan Tedder
of OneRepublic dance hits with DJs from
here in Ibiza and played in clubs here
like Robin Schultz and others but um but
this album very much as we going back to
why I got into music in the first place
as a form of expression as a catharsis a
way of expressing the things that go on
in my head and this time the difference
is they're not selfish songs about me
they're about people who are more
important than me and I've seen in my
parents and and my young family is this
an album that you could have made years
ago or is this something that has to
come from experience you know again
being a father and having gone through
all these different things in your life
I definitely couldn't have written it
there without the these experiences and
as I say even the song monsters with my
father getting old I couldn't have
written without young children just you
know I used their words in a song yeah
what do you want to say to the health
care workers I mean you just said it's
been a big year for you and you owe them
so much well I think the song says it
all for me really you know if the song
is called the greatest and and that's
who they are that's why it's dedicated
to them mm-hmm now you know on Instagram
you posted a picture that you drew of
the health care heroes James it says I
think is it done in crayon it's it's a
pretty fantastic drawing how your your
kids are the fans of your drawing skills
no I think they're probably much better
than mine so no I I think I know my
limitations
James when you're able to come out of
lockdown and able to you know freely
roam around the world again what's the
first thing that you want to do do you
know I mean it's here in Spain the
lockdown is effectively over now where
people can come back out here to Ibiza
from any country and we're allowed out
our bars are open and so what I can tell
is when it did to start the lockdown B
was being eased the first thing I went
to as a bar in an open square with the
sun shining and had a beer um but since
then I've you know we're on a tiny
island I've got a tiny little boat went
out on the water on MTC's looking at
empty beaches and and I say although
it's been tragic with the loss of life
through kovat I think it has been an
amazing time to recognize you know how
important family is and also they give
the planet a little bit of a rest human
consumption and I was on this tour
touring around the world laying a huge
carbon footprint and we will do that
again but I think the world deserved the
Mother Earth deserved a little bit of a
rest and maybe we should try doing this
again right on all right James thank you
so much for your time it was great
chatting with you lovely to talk to you
take care enjoy today